what if the truth of non-separation
is blatantly obvious
what if all you have to do is just look
at the pupil
and how it's the same pupil in
everyone's eyes
so you're always only with yourself
you're always only looking at yourself
you're always only talking to yourself
you're always only seeing yourself in
all kinds of
Dance Play
in that yourself that we're talking
about the pupil
is empty space
it's nothing
it's black hole
it's love
and so if you can just relax into that
black hole into that empty space
into that love
then you can transcend The Duality
between death and life
existence and non-existence
you can also transcend your own
suffering
if you want
because there's no one there anyway
so you can either have
a pinhole
that is joyous free loving playful
or you can have a pinhole
that is
suffering
that's mad it's angry
at seeing separation
that wants to fight
wants more for itself
so just check in when you were born
which you weren't it was just
the aperture
it's just that aperture
there's no birth it's just aperture
you're just aperturing
world world world world world world
world world world
just aperturing across infinite worlds
so you're never actually taking birth
you're never actually dying
and you don't have a name
it's empty space there's no name when
the aperture
opened up
to the world
it had no name no apertures have names
no pinholes have names
it's just a pupil
it's just a pupil the name is 100
conditioning
it's a relativism that has been
conditioned
that you were deeply baptized into an
indoctrinated by
for decades you have to dislodge your
name and recognize you don't have one
that is if you want to wake up
if you want to stay asleep which again
there is no Duality between the two
there's a simultaneity
so there's both no difference between a
sleep and awake that's non-dual and
there is an apparent difference because
if you are obsessed about your name and
obsessed about other people's names and
obsessed about separation
you'll suffer
but if you know that you're a pupil and
everyone's a pupil and there's only you
everywhere which is empty space there
will be no suffering
[Music]
we
so you got to be a little weird
you gotta allow yourself to just roll
with the flow
it could be eccentric
and totally normal
if you want to you can care about Earth
illusion of which
wants to continue being a playground
for many more apertures
to come
so you can build
sustainable regenerative
4D next-gen infrastructures
you can decentralize basic needs
but overall the obviousness of this it's
just so obvious it should lead you
directly to
paradox
should lead you directly to paradox
because you'll notice that you can't
take a direction from here
there's no direction I take
thank you
it's 100 directionless it's 100 Anarchy
because the empty hole is always already
free
so it doesn't care what direction any of
this goes in
it's Infinity why would it care
and yet at the same time
you just want to play
so if you want to play I want to build
these next-gen communities and
infrastructures go for it
be free
be free to
be
in high-rises in
mega cities
if that floats your boat
just remember there's no you
if you want to you can remember it's an
empty hole not everyone's an empty hole
or you can pretend like there are
separate people
with names
go for it
once you quote take this raft
and you make it across the river and you
recognize
wow
they're empty holes everywhere
there's no people there's no identities
there's nobody suffering there's nobody
experiencing Joy
nobody experiencing anything
there's no selves that are experiencing
there's only pure experience itself it's
like pure sensation pure perception
pure awareness or Consciousness itself
this camera on this iPhone doesn't
have a name
neither do you
it's obvious you don't see here going oh
my God my camera's name is Jeff
it's Susan I love you Susan I love you
so much I love you and your camera hole
is better than all other camera holes oh
nobody does that
nobody takes their iPhone camera hole
and gives it a name and then Compares it
to other iPhone camera holes
that doesn't happen
because it's not real
you would call those people psycho you'd
be like you're psycho you gave
your iPhone front facing camera a name
and you pet it and take care of it and
adore it with all your heart
and you compare it to other iPhone front
facing cameras
and pretend like those have names and
pretend like yours has greater priority
yes
yes you're the best dreamer possible in
that case
because you're so deeply steeped in
illusion
but you're free to
and I don't care if you wake up from
that or not
that's freedom
it's paradox
just think about how ridiculous
that is
this whole naming
camera holes
that's what these are
pure consciousness
empty space pupils
and we're naming them
just like you would
name
a iPhone camera haul
that's how ridiculously steeped in Drama
We Are
the theater of selves
it's up to you if you want to wake up or
not
totally up to you
and I'm starting to more and more
recognize the immediacy of things
there really is no path
you're already awake
so stop pretending like there are
separate people
recognize that your empty space and
everyone is empty space
that's what Infinity is
in all of these meat suits undergoing a
drama with itself
and that's all you
there's no one here other than you
so that's world peace right there
and it's a very direct path it's a very
direct pointing now
it's a very pathless path a very
gateless gate
like you're already not your name you're
already just pure empty space
now
if you want to
go on about there being a longer path
go for it
continue in that
if you feel like you need to
meditate to burn up your
defilements
go for it
if you need to heal more subconscious
traumas go for it
if you want to take more psychedelics go
for it
if you want to contract yourself even
deeper go for it
but when you feel this truth deep inside
yourself
your training ground
is life itself
because the purity of your empty space
of where you're coming from seeing
non-separation unconditionally loving
it's tested in life itself
in these creative ties of the cosmos
in this interconnected web
without centers
you see everyone's holding their their
iPhone camera right
and there's no differentiation between
those iPhone cameras so everyone's just
holding their phone cameras
you see it's the same thing as
Consciousness it's the same thing as the
pupil there's no differentiation
you don't go over there and say oh my
gosh your camera
oh my gosh you call it John
oh my gosh I call mine sadly
oh my God
like wow
that's so beautiful like
our cameras are different
oh my gosh everyone's camera is
different
go for it be my guest
eight billion different human cameras
go for it eight billion names
go for it
you're separate every camera is separate
be my guest
you're free to do so
in the true Paradox of it
is that the pinholes
appear
to be in different locations but they're
not
there is only one
web of pinholes
that's you you know this web of pinholes
this web of consciousness
you can pretend all you want that you're
not the web of Consciousness and that
you're
an individual
separate from other individuals go for
it
be free
that it's obvious my friend it's obvious
the movement of the cosmos is in this
direction
and then a cycle again
endless drama endless delusion endless
Play Endless contraction in this
expansion and that's your nature as
Infinity
endlessness
everything
happening
everywhere
at once
now
it's so obvious my friend just relax
into being empty space
iPhone cameras don't have names love you
peace